إنه أمر سيء على الأرض ،
حافظ على ذلك قليلاً ، يمكنك إخراج
الطفل من هنا ولكن في الهواء
يمكنك تحويل رجل بالغ إلى طفل يبكي
[موسيقى]
صوت
الراكب الذي يطلق النار على الفيديو
لم يتمكن مارك غرابوفسكي من خنقه  كانت
رحلة بابتسامة من الجنوب الغربي من بالتيمور إلى فورت
لودرديل تحوم بشكل دائري بسبب سوء
الأحوال الجوية ، يقول مارك إن الطفل كان
يبكي لمدة نصف ساعة تقريبًا عندما
انفجر الراكب المجهول ، لذا كان
الأشخاص على متن الطائرة معه أو ضده
كان الجميع ضده إلى حد كبير  قام
المعلقون عبر الإنترنت بتقسيم الطفل الوحيد في
تلك الرحلة ، وهو أن البالغ البالغ يعاني من
الانهيار الشديد مقابل إخوانه ، قال
الجزء الهادئ بصوت عالٍ جدًا ما قالته
مضيفة الطيران ، وهو الصراخ الجيد
للمرأة التي تسافر مع
الراكب الصاخب ، وضع رأسها في يدها
الطفل الباكي  كان بعيدًا عن The Irate
guy ، أخذوه إلى الجبهات
وتنازل الناس عن مقاعدهم ، وتم تحويل الطائرة
إلى أورلاندو
وأنا جيد ،
أخبرت شرطة أورلاندو CNN أنه لم يتم
القبض عليه ، قال Southwest إننا نقدر
صبر عملائنا الآخرين على
متن الطائرة الذين  اضطررت إلى تجربة مثل هذا
السلوك غير المقبول ، بدا المنحدر
مألوفًا مع ملصق واحد يمكنني رؤية
Samuel L Jackson يقول تلك السطور التي
مررت بها مع هذه
الثعابين اللعينة ولكن على الأقل الثعابين هادئة
ولكن ليس الركاب
نيويورك
[موسيقى]